uh William Barr was Donald Trump's Attorney
General and William Barr I do not consider a
friend of the Progressive Movement William Barr
is not someone I would even remotely consider
for attorney general but William Barr does have
some legal expertise there is no question about
that and William Barr went on Fox News Sunday and
said that if half of the new Federal indictment
Federal indictment against Trump is true Trump is
toast this is super interesting stuff it wildly
triggered Donald Trump let's listen to what Barr
had to say and he's making a lot of sense here
um what about this this Chief argument that comes
up for the president's allies and his legal team
that this should have been handled under the
presidential records act not this espion act
Espionage Act charge in other Federal statutes
that were used here well it started out under the
presidential records act and and the archives
trying to retrieve documents that Trump had
no right to have but it quickly became clear that
what the government was really worried about were
these classified and very sensitive documents I
was shocked by the degree of sensitivity of these
documents and how many there were frankly and
uh so the government's agenda was to get those
uh protect those documents and get them out and I
think it was perfectly appropriate to do that it
was the right thing to do and I think the counts
under the Espionage Act that he willfully retained
those documents or solid counts now I I do think
we have to wait and see what the defense says
and and what proves to be true but I do think
that even half what Andy McCarthy said which
is if even half of it is true then he's toast I
mean it's a it's a pretty it's a very detailed
indictment and it's very very damning okay
that is an extraordinary statement and it also
sort of deals with one of the claims that
so-called legal experts like Mark Levin are
making which is that this stuff isn't even really
related to the criminal world of law that this
is all just presidential records act subject
to that and William Barr says sure initially
it was subject to that but between based on the
evidence in the indictment which includes alleged
obstruction and it includes all of these other
things that Trump is accused of doing it becomes
criminal and that's that's it it's short you can
say until you're you're blue in the face this is
presidential record stuff it went criminal when
Trump covered it up tried to keep the documents
potentially tried to destroy documents etc etc
uh and that is absolutely very very serious
stuff then we go to Fox news's favorite legal
commentator Jonathan Turley Jonathan Turley has
been defending Trump reflexively for year years
now on so many different issues even Jonathan
Turley says this is a very damning indictment
listen to this president gozad to say well what
if we what happens if we just don't respond at
all to The subpoena I guess or don't play ball
with them the president goes on to say wouldn't
it be better if we just told them we don't have
anything here well look isn't it better if there
are no documents uh you know they they've got
these conversations that were memorialized by the
president's attorneys there's also this recording
of him where he talks about this plan that's
believed an attack plan against Iran I mean
they've got a lot of information in this Jonathan
no it is an extremely damning indictment uh you
know there are indictments there are sometimes
called narrative or speaking indictments these
are indictments uh that are really meant to uh
make a point as to the depth of the evidence there
are some indictments that are just Bare Bones
this is not uh the special counsel uh knew that
there would be a lot of people who were going
to allege uh that the Department of Justice was
acting in a biased or politically motivated way
this is clearly an indictment uh that was drafted
to answer those questions it's overwhelming and
detailed and you know the Trump team should not
fool itself these are hits below the water
line uh these are witnesses who apparently
testified under oath gave statements to Federal
investigators both of which can be criminally
charged if they're false those Witnesses
are directly quoting the president uh in in
encouraging others not to look for documents or
allegedly to conceal them it's damaging and the
key here to keep in mind is that every case I've
ever been involved with the indictment was a Heart
Stopper you know these are written by lawyers who
are trying to convict a client every indictment
I've ever dealt with has fallen apart to some
degree once we look more carefully about the
evidence may be but this is is not a an indictment
that you can dismiss all right so there is
Jonathan Turley even with his hemming and hawing
saying this is very serious stuff back to William
Barr William Barr putting the blame for all of
this squarely on Trump and that's where it should
be so and we can't forget here that this entire
thing came about because of Reckless conduct
of the president if he had just turned over the
documents which I think every other person in
the country would have done the government's
documents their official records they're not
his personal records battle plans for an attack on
another country or or defense department documents
about our capabilities are in no universe
Donald J Trump's personal documents and
then lastly from William Barr Trump's claims that
other presidents did the same thing Barr debunks
it good for him to his credit he is undoing
every single one of these Trump arguments this
took all these documents those were situations
where they arranged with the archives to set
up special space under the management control and
security provided by the archivist to temporarily
put documents until the libraries were ready
because we're not people just putting them
in their basement okay and the second thing
that the president this idea that that that
the president has complete authority to
declare any document personal is obvious
it's facially ridiculous that opinion had
to do with the distinction between official
records which are records prepared by government
agencies for the purpose of government action
and personal documents as opposed to official
documents which are things prepared by the
president such as a diary or notes which are
not used in the government's deliberations
and yes as to the second class stuff that the
president himself generates the president has
some discretion but these are official
documents it's an arguable yep listen
um William Barr you don't have to like them
to recognize that he is on much stronger legal
footing here than a random Fox news commentator
indignantly saying there's nothing here William
Barr is right and that's why it so triggered
Donald Trump when he said this let's talk about
that briefly next people often ask me about my
daily routine you know I'm interviewed about the
David Pacman show how did you do it how do you do
this and like daily routine just often comes up
and how do you stay healthy and of course I talk
about exercise and I talk about eating the right
diet but one of the things that can happen if
you are not eating the right diet diet or you're
traveling or life gets in the way is you end
up with some kind of vitamin deficiency a daily
scoop of ag-1 from our sponsor athletic greens
makes this super easy to take off of your list of
things to worry about one scoop of ag1 you get the
entire day's worth of 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals from Whole Food sourced ingredients ag-1
is cheaper than dealing with a bunch of different
supplements it's infinitely more convenient you
just take a scoop before you have your coffee for
example as I do in the morning and you're covered
for the entire day many of my friends love ag1
anyone I mention it to seems to get hooked when I
go on vacation I bring the ag1 travel packs with
me especially because I'm not always eating
the same diet when I'm traveling that I do at
home staying properly nourished so important
to feeling your best ag1 just makes it really
easy and very convenient go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman to get a free year supply of vitamin D I've
talked about vitamin D so many times plus five
free ag1 travel packs the link is down below